[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de Honduras porque el
gobierno de la presidenta Xiomara Castro
le declaró el día jueves en la guerra
contra la extorsión que ejercen las
pandillas sobre los comerciantes un
flagelo que ha dejado centenares de
muertos y muchos negocios en la ruina
frente a esto desde el pasado domingo
más de 600 policías militares patrullan
en la fronteras con el Salvador
Guatemala y Nicaragua en esta lucha
contra las bandas criminales salemos a
Tiziano bredeles analista para
Centroamérica el International prises
Group gracias a Tiziano por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de martes en
directo América de Francia 24 y le
preguntó para comenzar nuestra
conversación sobre la situación actual
de las pandillas en Honduras y Qué tan
grave es la extorsión en ese país
centroamericano
bueno Muchas gracias gracias por la
invitación y buenos días
la semana Castro respectivamente tuvo
que responder a lo que era un digamos un
llamado creciente una progresión popular
creciente respecto al tema de la
extorsión
y que es un fenómeno muy difundido
Aunque
históricamente concentrado en las
ciudades más grandes del país que son
Tegucigalpa la capital y San Pedro Sula
en el norte y algunas otras ciudades
pero el tema es que la percepción fue
que en este año donde hubo una
transición
de tareas de seguridad pública donde la
presidenta Castro en su idea de
desmilitarización le quitó el control de
los centros penales y de las actividades
antimaras y pandillas al ejército y se
los dio a la Policía Nacional civil que
pero posiblemente no estaba preparada
todavía para pues expandir tanto sus
operaciones
Bueno este año Parece que la razón de
esto este fenómeno estuviese creciendo
incluso territorialmente geográficamente
estaba llegando territorios muy lejanos
muy Rurales departamentos Santa Bárbara
y Copán en occidente Choluteca en el sur
Colón en el centro y efectivamente
además fue un tema de que no es fácil
digamos calcularlo en términos del
número porque a nivel de denuncias no no
está bien
estructurada digamos la recuperación de
datos pero a nivel mediático si se les
da mucho peso había tomado una
relevancia enorme incluso Pues los
transportistas habían hecho un paro por
la ciudad de Tegucigalpa muy fuerte para
pues protestar contra el hecho de que sí
sentían que había una cierta inoperancia
contra la extorsión Tiziano pero también
este problema digamos no viene desde
estos años recientes sino incluso 12 u 8
años atrás porque también en la
mandataria Xiomara Castro él dijo que
frente estos últimos ocho años de su
antecesor Juan Orlando Hernández un
cartel de drogas pues se permeó en todas
las instituciones del estado elevando
evidentemente la violencia la extorsión
la formación de más organizaciones es
criminales que tan cierto ahí sobre esta
declaración de Xiomara Castro de la
permeabilidad de las instituciones por
parte de bandas criminales Durante los
últimos años de Juan Manuel Hernández
bueno en Honduras seguramente hay una
debilidad histórica de las instituciones
una desafortunadamente una corrupción
bastante
digamos que tiene un alcance bastante
amplio dentro de las instituciones esto
ha sido empeorado por el El golpe de
estado que ha sido utilizado por
estructuras criminales sobre todo
dedicadas al narcotráfico para
expandir sus operaciones y a aprovechar
del caos un poco de las debilitamientos
de las de las instituciones para pues
infiltrarse Por así decirlo en varios en
varias instituciones no son a nivel
político sino a nivel judicial en las
fuerzas de seguridad etcétera
Además hay un tema que es deuda
histórica que tiene el país que es del
control de las cárceles desde ahí llegan
la mayoría o sin por lo menos buena
parte de las llamadas exorcivas
de parte de los cabecillas de pandillas
y a pesar de que el gobierno Holanda
Hernández lo había había en el control
bajo los militares pensando que pues
hubiese eso abonarse a que tomara
control de esta situación en cambio pues
este este sostenimiento penitenciarios
pues han quedado como centros operativos
de estos grupos y y esto sí es
efectivamente no es un problema de este
gobierno en especial sino es una deuda
histórica que tiene el país sí Y también
ante este estado de emergencia declarado
por
Xiomara Castro en su declaración de la
guerra contra las pandillas sobre todo
la extorsión desde ya el pasado domingo
más de 600 policías militares están
Entonces patrullando esta fronteras con
el Salvador Guatemala y Nicaragua que
tanto puede evitar entonces las
autoridades en estas amplias fronteras
que no se sigan cometiendo actos
extorsión sobre todo para los
comerciantes fronterizos para los
comerciantes de esa zona y que las
bandas criminales digamos de esos otros
países Centroamericanos pues tengan
permeando entre Honduras
efectivamente ahí el digamos la misión
no me ha quedado totalmente claras Y la
misión es la de incentivar o no permitir
el ingreso de de pandilleros de
criminales de otros estados cercanos en
el país porque se estima que ellos estén
contribuyendo no a la expansión de este
fenómeno que es una de las posibles
interpretaciones también porque
efectivamente han salido muchos
pandilleros salvadoreños del Salvador en
estos meses de máxima presión en donde
en El Salvador pues se Han detenido ya
58 mil personas
mayoría de las cuales pues efectivamente
miembros de pandillas o sea una media
preventiva para digamos en el momento en
que se impongan esos estados de
excepción que todavía tengo entendido
Pues están identificando las zonas la
policía está sugiriendo unas 160
colonias y comunidades
a la presidenta al consejo de ministros
para que se apruebe un régimen de
excepción en esos lugares pero me parece
que a nivel operativo no hayan empezado
las operaciones de depresión entonces no
sé si es una medida preventiva para
controlar mejor las fronteras para que
en el momento en que haya estos
operativos y aumenta la presión contra
las familias pues se prevenga la salida
de de criminales hondureños a las
fronteras hacia las fronteras hacia los
países vecinos también Tiziano podemos
ver pues toda esta cuestión de otro
enfoque sería también una medida de
presión digamos la presidenta se llamará
Castro se habría visto presionada ante
unos resultados digamos durante estos
primeros meses al mando al mando de
Honduras también en comparación con la
situación en El Salvador con el
presidente
nayib bukele va a ser así de fuerte esta
represión contra Las pandillas en
Honduras como la que vemos en el
Salvador
Mira a nivel mediático Yo creo que es
indudable que se ha visto como
estos términos no guerra contra la
extorsión como es guerra contra
pandillas en El Salvador
estado de excepción como medida a
implementar son es un términos que que
pasen parte de una estrategia mediática
y operativa en El Salvador que es muy
exitosa tanto a nivel por lo menos
temporalmente de eficacia de resultados
como nivel de popularidad pública no de
a nivel de apoyo creo que más del 80% de
los salvadoreños en cada encuesta Pues
dice si están contento con lo que está
haciendo ukele y esto se expande Más
allá de las fronteras del Salvador es
son medidas que que circulan en videos y
tal entonces hay un apoyo muy grande a
nivel regional a lo que está haciendo el
presidente bucara en el Salvador
entonces retomar el discurso
posiblemente pues tiene ese objetivo de
intentar Pues ganar puntos políticos no
como se está haciendo en El Salvador a
nivel práctico pero yo creo que no sea
posible tiene mucha limitante o de
semana Castro para implementar un estado
de excepción tan amplio y y tan fuerte
como lo está haciendo bukelele en El
Salvador en primer lugar porque no tiene
capacidad operativa o sea las fuerzas
policiales y de seguridad y de perdón
militares en la seguridad pública en
Honduras son unos 38.000 si no estoy mal
en El Salvador son 45 hasta 50.000
recientemente con la expansión del
ejército en un país que es casi la mitad
de extensión y de población
las cárceles están completamente ya
desbordadas en muy pocas muy pequeñas en
Honduras y ya tiene un 300% de capacidad
Entonces sería muy difícil traer como
que se que se inflan otra vez más
y a nivel sobre todo de digamos de
control del de todas las instituciones
de partes esto le falta ukele ya tiene
influencia en El Ejecutivo en el
legislativo en el órgano judicial y en
el control de las fuerzas de seguridad
Por lo cual no ha enfrentado ningún tipo
de de depresión de crítica de debate
sobre la constitucionalidad de extender
indefinidamente este estado de excepción
no ha habido rendición de cuentas sobre
pues posibles de tensiones arbitrarias o
muertes que estén ocurriendo en las
cárceles porque hay un control muy
fuerte muy férreo muy fuerte sobre las
demás instituciones incluso las que
tienen que velar por los derechos y que
tienen que investigar los hechos
entonces en en Honduras
Xiomara no tiene este tipo de influencia
este tipo de control por lo tanto puede
que lo implemente a nivel local
localizado por por un tiempo pero me
resultaría muy difícil creer que lo vaya
a extender y expandir tanto a nivel
nacional en el tiempo porque va a
enfrentar mucho más obstáculos ahora
Tiziano eso el caso digamos de Honduras
y El Salvador pero nos salimos de la
fronteras de estos países también para
hablar de esta región o centroamericana
sería también eh con el último paso de
Honduras o una medida de presión que
puedan sentir los otros gobiernos de la
región centroamericana como para tomar
más medidas contundentes contra las
bandas criminales contra el crimen
organizado en este caso también las
pandillas para que sea también más un
esfuerzo conjunto entre toda la región
centroamericana la lucha contra este
flagelo
bueno seguramente hay muchos ojos
puestos sobre lo que está ocurriendo en
Honduras sobre lo que está ocurriendo en
El Salvador si esta estrategia de estado
de excepción que se traduzca
posiblemente en un aumento de capturas y
de depresión sobre estos grupos
criminales pero tiene una unos
resultados positivos también en Honduras
en reducir los índices de violencia y de
criminalidad a veces indudable que cada
vez más gobernantes no solamente en
Centroamérica sino en toda latinoamérica
pues estén pendientes de ver si
si pueden replicar este tipo de medidas
cada quien con sus limitantes Como por
ejemplo la que estaba describiendo sobre
Honduras pero que puedan incluso
solamente a nivel discursivo no este
intentar Pues aprovechar de este tipo de
estrategia que te parece tan tan exitosa
a nivel político y a nivel operativo yo
creo que sobre todo Guatemala esté
mirando muy este fenómeno incluso pues
entra en un año electoral por lo tanto
Pues podría ser esto un elemento que
podría jugar en algún papel en la
campaña incluso estamos hablando Tiziano
digamos del problema pero yéndonos un
poco también el origen como iniciamos
nuestra conversación se trata también
una permeabilidad de las instituciones
en Centroamérica que no son tan fuertes
no contra también la corrupción y con
otros intereses de bandas criminales que
de alguna manera han llegado hasta el
poder Cómo hacer realmente para
fortalecer estas instituciones y para
que esto nos siga pasando Desde el
origen No desde el origen del estado y
por qué también una segunda pregunta ya
también para finalizar nuestra
conversación Tiziano con toda la ayuda
de Estados Unidos económica y digamos
apoyo político porque también la región
centroamericana no ha podido luchar
contra todo esto digamos que también
está la la descripción volvemos a la
primera pregunta sería el origen de todo
Dónde están esos fondos también que ha
invertido Estados Unidos en esta región
Claro Mira te voy a usar las palabras de
un fiscal con el que hablé hace hace
poco tiempo si la cabeza está mal el
cuerpo no puede estar bien entonces el
problema realmente es muy de fondo
porque hay mucha gente comprometida en
las instituciones en la fiscalía
ministerio público en las fuerzas de
seguridad en los juzgados pero
si si la voluntad política es la que
falta porque hay algún tipo de
involucramiento en algunos casos pues al
más alto nivel lo mismo con buenos
Orlando Hernández que ahorita está está
enfrentando juicio para narcotráfico en
Nueva York pero también hay casos no de
de de de indicios de corrupción de alto
nivel Incluso en el gobierno de
Guatemala y y bueno en general los
gobiernos de la región
si ahí está el digamos hasta hasta ahí
han llegado los intereses de grupos
criminales y de corrupción y se dedica
más tiempo muchísimos recursos a
intentar por ejemplo perseguir a ex
Fiscales de la cc de la fiscalía
especial contra la corrupción como es el
grado de Guatemala no y y incluso
opositores políticos este no va a jugar
al favor ningún favor digamos para la
efectividad la eficacia de las
instituciones en luchar contra contra la
criminalidad entonces realmente habría
que tener un cambio y una mayor voluntad
política desde arriba y claramente
habría que potenciar y proteger y
mejorar las condiciones de trabajo de
los de los juzgados y de los de los
fiscales que llevan decenas sino
centenares de casos
a la vez y no no están desbordados y
enfrentan mucho peligro porque estas
personas criminales que tienen mucho
poder y incluso pues de amenaza y de
violencia contra ellos mismos